stopping the boats as the Prime Minister
puts it is one of his key priorities and
now we know how he plans to do it
the government poised to unveil a new
law preventing those who arrive like
this from being able to stay what
promise is saying is that we also need
some legislation on top of what we are
doing so we can make sure that people
who come to this country illegally are
returned very quickly and I that's I
what I expect to see in the legislation
it's understood the legislation will ban
people who travel in small boats from
claiming Asylum here
the government will have powers to
deport them to Rwanda or another safe
Third Country but campaigners believe it
won't work I don't think it will have
any effect anecdotally speaking to
people that have made the journey that
have recently been in Calais you know
they talk about the government's
initiatives but everybody has made this
decision to get to the UK and they're
going to do it the government knows this
you know they're lying to people when
they say that they have a solution it's
just more performative cruelty from this
government
more than 45
000 people cross the channel in small
boats last year that's up more than 60
percent on 2021. the latest figures for
this year show nearly 3 000 have arrived
so far this is by no means the first
proposal to bring those numbers down in
recent years we've seen more border
Force vessels patrolling the channel
we've seen the Navy put in charge of
operations and of course last year we
saw that controversial plan to deport
some Asylum Seekers to Rwanda but all
the time the numbers only increase and
it's made this issue more highly charged
than ever
in Dover on Saturday an illustration of
that
far-right protesters coming face to face
with anti-fascist demonstrators
disturbing divisions that are at risk of
only deepening further
the South Coast may be on the front line
of this issue with the tensions it's
creating are gripping the whole country
either Bennett Sky News folkestone